my name is Wyatt Perl I'm a product
engineer at Giant and you can find links
to the slides and everything I'm going
to talk about today at my website at JSC
ich komm slash nerd summit so I want to
start by telling a children's story
actually think that children's stories
are pretty useful I learned quite a bit
whenever I'm reading them to my kids for
example I was reading llama llama
red pajama and that taught me how to do
callbacks or Chicken Little actually
taught me about cascading failure and so
I took Chicken Little and I definitely
took liberties with it so I have an
adaptation of Chicken Little and I'm
calling it chicken micro so let's let's
begin one day a chicken micro was making
a request to the corn server when boom
the request timed out goodness gracious
the server's must be down I must go and
tell the system operator so chicken
micro went along until she came to Boxey
Loxy where are you going in such a hurry
asked Foxy Loxy I'm going to tell the
operator that the servers are down I
made a request and never got a response
oh dear I'll go with you so chicken
micro and boxy Loxy went along until
they came to robot Rob where are you
going in such a hurry asked robot Rob
we're going to tell the operator that
the servers are down chicken micro made
a request to never got a response I'll
go with you so chicken micro Foxy Loxy
and robot Rob made it to the system
operator I made a request to the corn
server and the request timed out the
servers are down Oh chicken micro the
servers are not down but the server the
load balancer sent you to was under
heavy load please try your request again
so we can learn some lessons from
chicken micro for example
if your server is overloaded respond
with a 503 and ideally your load
balancer or whatever will take you out
of rotation but even if we did have a
load balancer in the mix how would
chicken micro know that the next request
would even succeed because chicken micro
doesn't know the health of the servers
behind the load balancer and so this
brings me to a point where as you're
moving from micro services and you're
trying to re are c't X or monolith
sometimes you you leak over your
monolithic architecture and this can
bring about some of the same issues you
had with your monolith but before I get
too far ahead of myself I definitely
need to clarify what I mean by micro
service because there's lots of
definitions people have varying thoughts
on it but when I describe a micro
service I'm talking about a small
service and ideally it's the decomposed
from a monolith and I think most
importantly each service needs to be
able to be isolated and independently
deployable and lastly you should be
stateless so that it's easy to scale out
your services and from these
characteristics we can get a lot of
benefits because it's able to be
independently deployed you are able to
embrace failure so if your other
dependencies are down it won't impact
you and from this you can actually move
very quickly you can deliver lots of
business value if something doesn't work
out you can just tear down that service
and try again because everything is so
tiny ideally and able to be
independently deployable but there are
definitely some anti patterns that we
run into especially as we move from the
monolith to the micro services so
there's a very helpful book by Mark
Richards called micro services anti
patterns and pitfalls I encourage you to
go check it out at storm o'reilly and
it's actually free so even more reason
but I want to focus on a couple anti
patterns today so the
balancer between micro-services and then
how startup order can matter so if we
look at the situation with chicken micro
where the load balancer was between the
micro-services chicken micro had a
timeout and how would chicken micro know
when to make the next request
do you just retry immediately well how
do you know that there are other servers
that are even healthy behind that load
balancer so you have that disconnect
when you have a load balancer situated
between your micro services and even if
you had a 503 response telling you like
retry in a minute how would you know
that that would succeed or maybe you
could have just reached right
immediately because there could be other
servers that are healthy and lastly the
startup order matters is another
anti-pattern I think because everything
should be independently deployable you
really shouldn't be tied to assuming
that your database is up for example so
in this this code snippet we're trying
to make a connection to my sequel and
we're binding herself to a DB host
through the environment variable another
issue with this too is if that host
changes you're gonna have to restart the
entire process because it's an
environment variable and then if the
database is not up you're not really
handling into that so you have to think
about things differently you have to
really are assume that not everything is
going to be working whenever your
application starts or when your micro
service starts goodness gracious
are there any patterns that can help me
well fortunately there are so the one I
want to focus on is the autopilot
pattern it is not geared specifically
for micro services but it actually lends
itself well to helping with the issues
that I highlighted so the main goals of
the autopilot pattern or that you're
able to build applications that can be
deployed and scaled very easily easily
your application and the workflow that
you
used to create that application should
work the same on your development laptop
as any it should work the same in any
cloud or data center and you shouldn't
be tied to a specific cloud or
infrastructure and so we do have a
website explaining more about the
autopilot pattern just autopilot
patterned at i/o I encourage you to
check that out we also have quite a few
example applications so we have a
autopilot pattern github organization
with examples of MongoDB my sequel
influx and then we even have full
blueprint applications like WordPress
that are using this pattern and
typically all of those examples that we
have are using docker and containers and
to do that we have a tool a free and
open source tool called container pilot
which I'll talk about in a little bit
but because we don't have that load
balancer between the services we do need
a way to discover you know what services
are where and if they're healthy or not
and so to do that we use console and we
also because we're using console don't
have to expose any health checks outside
of the container so this makes it very
easy to to container eyes and container
pilot eyes I guess the the databases so
you can have your health check query
your database and make sure everything
is working correctly and report back to
a console that you're you're healthy so
to kind of explain more about what this
actually means in practice I have a node
example so I'm using --happy which is a
wonderful module I hope you all check it
out if you haven't already using piloted
which I wrote specifically to work with
this pattern and then rec for making
requests so this is the the diagram of
the application I'm going to show you
you don't need to understand all of it
but just the general idea is that we
have IOT sensor data coming in and it's
pushed to Nats which is a message
queuing system and then we have three
workers pulling that sensor data off
humidity in motion and temperature and
that pushes it to the serializer which
is then saved to influx DB and on the
front end we have the front end which
exposes some grass so let me show you
what this looks like so right now I have
it running it's it it's all using docker
so I started it with docker compose so
this is a dashboard of consul and you
can see all the services and they're
green they're all healthy and this is
the front end with as you can see random
random data since I don't actually have
the smartthings hub here but the nice
thing is I can stop any of those
services and everything that depended on
it will be notified immediately so I can
stop the serializer so that'll go down
and then container pilot will realize
that that service is not healthy and
stop sending a heartbeat to console so
if I go back to console refresh and see
the serializer
is no longer healthy and the workers
actually are able to respond to that and
not even try to make a request because
they know there's nothing that they can
make a request to so you don't have that
failure and similarly the front-end
knows that the serializer is down so it
stops making requests back to that but
if you bring it back up everything
starts working again
so everything well the the time series
data is not the easiest to work with
there so everything starts working again
and responding to that change in your
environment so you have a lot of self
healing qualities built into this
so let's go back so I wanted to
highlight some of the code snippets that
make this possible this is from the
serializer
and I'm using the piloted module which
just keeps a local cache of whatever
services the serializer cares about in
this case so give me a healthy address
for in Flex DB and then you can see if I
don't have one
I'm just going to use an in-memory
database but if I do then I'll create a
connection so that's how you achieve
that isolation so being able to handle
the case where you don't have any
healthy dependencies and to respond to
the change events so if the in Flex DB
comes up again then we'll send a signal
to the process and piloted will handle
that and give you an event to reload and
reconnect to the database or not at all
and the way we achieve this is with a
lot of help from container pilot which
runs inside the container and it'll
register each of the services for you
with console it takes care of providing
some lifecycle hooks and gives you
out-of-the-box telemetry reporting with
Prometheus and we started it as an init
process because it's running as pit one
so it'll actually take care of reaping
any child processes or child zombie
processes and do your health checks for
you register your service as I said and
and watch and notify you if anything
changes and you can find the source code
for it it's written and go but it's on
our joint org under your container pilot
and so you control container pilot with
a very simple configuration file we're
using JSON 5 now it also supports JSON
if that's what you're into but you
configure it with what you care about so
the watches this is again the serializer
so I'm watching for any changes and in
Flex DB so if more instances come up or
they go down tell me about it and we can
figure that through the job which will
send a sick up signal to your node
process it actually doesn't restart the
process because we're handling that
signal and we're refreshing our local
cache of the healthy addresses and to
configure your service that you want
registered you just need to tell
container pilot what port you're gonna
listen on and give it a health check so
in this case I just have a curl command
that's just hitting localhost and
that'll keep sending a heartbeat to
console to let it know that you're still
healthy or not and so because of this
we're actually able to do some of the
patterns that you would have would also
see in micro-services land like circuit
breakers in so a while back we actually
built into happy this load feature so
it'll respond with a 503 if your process
is under too much load which you define
what that means can be memory or in this
case the event loop delay getting too
bogged down and so in this case if your
process gets too bogged down you're not
healthy anymore and then all of the
other micro services that depended on
you are notified and will stop calling
you but we do need load balancing
somewhere
since you're likely to have more than
one service that you're calling write
more instances more than one instance of
that service that you're calling so
piloted out of the box we just do
round-robin load balancing but you can
decide however you want to load balance
your requests on the client it could be
random it could be round-robin it's
really up to you so I want to also
highlight how cool this is with scaling
so I have Nats running here and I just
have one instance of it and Nats
operates by clustering itself together
like you would typically have to
configure what you know
instances 2.22 cluster but because we're
using console to discover other Nats
instances we can actually cluster
automagically I'll say so I'll just use
the scale command from dr. Campos and we
can add more instances this of the
serializer we can also add more
instances of Nats and little docker will
spin up these new instances for us and
as they come online they'll be
registered with console so if we go back
to console we can start to see more
instances coming up so now we have three
instances of Nats running and Nats is
also we have a container pilot solution
for it so it'll auto cluster itself so
you don't have to do any configuration
it just knows from talking to console
that there are other Nats instances once
this refreshes so it clustered itself to
the other other instances there and then
again you could scale it up more or
bring it down it's really whatever you
want let's see so even though I was kind
of disparaging load balancers between
your services they still definitely have
a purpose more at the edge more as a API
gateway so in this case I was using
traffic and Express gateway there are
lots of solutions out there so
definitely keep that in mind don't
entirely expose your micro services
directly to your customers so the last
point I want to make is about telemetry
reporting so we support Prometheus out
of the box and you can report on any
metric you care about again I like the
event loop delay so in this example I'm
just configuring container pilot to
report on the event loop delay for me
and then Prometheus will recognize that
and and console and go out and start
pulling in
the data from every instance as it comes
up so this is what you would see in
Prometheus to see the event loop delay
so if you want to learn more we have
auto pilot pattern do I have links again
if you go to a node summit off of my
website and then there's some other
links there for you as well so thank you
[Applause]